[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled applications of multiplex
digital pcr
monitoring wastewater for stars kobe 2
and measuring bacterial gene expression
i'm christy joula flappard and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinths and sponsored by
thermo fisher scientific
for more information on our sponsor
please visit thermofisher.com
now let's get started
you may participate by submitting as
many questions as you like at any time
you like during the presentation to do
so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click submit
i now present today's speaker
joan slanzewski professor of biology at
kenyon college for a complete biography
honor speaker please visit the biography
tab at the top of your screen
joan you may now begin your presentation
so thank you for that introduction and
i'm excited to be here today
describing our
experiences with developing wastewater
virus monitoring for a small community
so uh back in 2020 as the pandemic got
started
our small village of gambier in ohio was
interested in how we could
use
some of the signals available from
molecular biology to give information to
the community about the pandemic and you
can see here the
well what it looks like in gambiar ohio
people had a lot of questions like
should we wear masks the the mayor
had a big meeting as to whether there
should be a mask mandate for the village
and people wanted to know should they go
to a restaurant and
the information was always very delayed
so there's a dashboard of public cases
but it could be a a week or two before
you would see
the actual results of cases
so wastewater
monitoring for virus was something that
was being developed by a number of labs
in ohio
state of ohio is actually at the
forefront of this effort and so we
participated in that
so what we did is
we
developed a method to monitor
shed virus
in particular the rna from shed rna
viruses
from the village of gambier wastewater
treatment plant and actually the idea of
monitoring
viruses of
of
viral rna has been around for 20 years
and there were literature techniques to
do it
and
this particular virus there there were
public published
probes and and pcr
amplification probes that the same ones
that are used in clinical testing turned
out to be usable in wastewater
so
the village of gambier the wastewater
treatment plant
is actually it's a small plant only a
hundred thousand gallons per day and
it's a pretty tight plant there's not
too much infiltration so
it was a good case in a number of ways
now the village population
is small it happens to include about
two-thirds of the population are
undergraduate students from kenyon
college who live in residence halls in
very close quarters and so there's the
opportunity for rapid spreading of virus
there
now
during the past year
there was a a community dashboard that
posted
the results for active cases
both from gambier and then there was
also a college dashboard so we had case
data and the case data are shown in red
the published cases of course we know
that there are many cases of
of sars pope to that
that escape actual appearance
with
with symptoms
so
it was of interest to to monitor
can we detect the rna from virus of
people that are not infected as well as
those who are infected
so what you see here is
the results that we were able to obtain
with the thermo fisher instrument
you can see that the the blue curve
indicates
the log2 rna copies per liter that we
were able to measure
and we can see the
the progress of that over the last fall
and the corresponding data from
case reports in red
so the interesting thing is that as has
been shown elsewhere the ohio state
monitoring group and others have shown
that wastewater does act as a leading
indicator of cases so that
that
the viral rna appears in the wastewater
about a week ahead of typically case
reports
then once you have a spike in cases
the
wastewater rna levels do tend to lag
behind so it's considered a lagging
indicator of haste decline
what happens is that people that are
still shedding virus it
are
combined with people that
are new infections
so if you see if you see the
wastewater levels declining about a half
per week that's a good indication that
virus in general is declining that you
don't have new cases but the most
important thing for people in the
village was that you have this leading
indicator that you can see that there's
an infection spike starting before the
cases are actually reported and that's
useful for somebody considering well am
i going to go out to a restaurant this
weekend things like that
so what was the technology that we used
and so
basically we
went and obtained wastewater samples
from the influence of the village plant
and so we see here a wastewater sample
and a couple of tubes that have salt the
salt rapidly inactivates most pathogens
that would be in the waste water i
should add that we assume and this all
the literature has borne this out that
that the cyroscop2 virus
is rapidly inactivated in the wastewater
prior that what you're detecting is rna
from inactivated virus
there is not believed to be infectious
virus in the wastewater
we would obtain the samples
in the morning from an auto sampler that
had
cycled every 15 minutes
to get to get an average
sampling over the past 24 hours
and
we then took it back to the college
where
my students and i conducted
an rna purification
and the
purification method that we use there
are a variety of different tools for
purification but we we did the simplest
possible purification that we could find
which was from
from
the berkeley university
out there on on the internet
and so
basically what you do is you first
inactivate with nacl
then
you assume that viruses and other
pathogens are lysed and that any any rna
is removed from particles you filter
that wastewater now the filtration that
we used did retain
some small particles particles smaller
than five micrometers
so there is in the literature there's
some
sense that
some of the rna
viral rna is actually adherent to the
particulate matter of wastewater which
is a very complicated fluid so we're
capturing some of that
in our prep
then this is ethanol treated
and and
treated with a buffer that should remove
most of the rna from any
particulates and pass through
a lysate
through through the zymo silica spin
column this is a spin column
of silica that specifically attaches
nucleic acids and most other stuff pours
through
and in the
early way we took
concentrated rna the rna would have been
concentrated about 400 fold from the
original sample
and this was a process that was simple
enough that i could do and also
my undergraduate students we two
undergraduate students were actually
hired to help out doing this
so here is one of them bailey fitzgerald
and here she is
setting up to run the absolute q
instrument to
measure the amount of viral rna
in the samples
so the assay that we used was
assay that was developed by
carbonari before they were bought out by
thermo fisher
so the combination fourplex assay
includes
four different floors in four different
tacman probes for different primer sets
so
the primer sets n1 and n2 those are
based on the standard cdc primers that
are used in all the the swab tests
the bovine coronavirus was for a control
coronavirus there was some debate as to
the usefulness of that we eventually
decided that we did not
require that control that we felt it was
not really relevant to the stars co2
virus but then a very important control
is the
pepper
model virus
the which is a fecal model
indicator and so
that virus
was detected with uh the tie for so we
used those three and later versions of
the probemix were threeplex and included
just those three
floors
so in order to
to perform this
we did use the absolute q instrument in
which there are 16 wells
and
each well for a sample so for each
sample that the final sample volume is
to be nine microliters exactly so this
included the
the forex or three
the four excuse me the the
four-fold concentrated uh master mix
that includes the reverse transcriptase
then uh
20-fold concentrate of the probe mix
and the rna sample and there's room for
about two-thirds of the volume consists
of the rna sample
we also
ended up by second semester we started
using
a specific probe for a variant which was
the omicron variant so we did not do
that first semester in the data i showed
but for this current semester we've been
using the omicron twoplex probe which
was also developed by fissure and this
is based on the spike gene
a particular mutation the spike gene in
which glycine is replaced by
by
a different
amino acid and by aspartate and
so there are two probes that
compare the omicron variant result with
the standard reference which would have
been the delta variant at that time and
it turned out that both probes were able
to work under the same settings
so
i should also mention the rna sample
that we used we found
by experiment that the rna actually
required some dilution because
the rna has
had some pcr
pcr inhibitors in it and this has been
generally found with wastewater
monitoring so we experimented with
dilutions and we found that that if you
diluted five-fold or ten-fold that your
signal actually increased
so we ended up routinely diluting the
sample
in tea a buffer before including it
so here's what the instrument readout
looks like so for a typical run this
would take
two columns of the 16 well plate
and we would
have two independent samples of the
wastewater from that day
and
for each sample in column one
we would
assay
the fivefold dilution and the tenfold
dilution of the wastewater and then in
column two we did the same thing
but
used the omicron probe test instead the
cycle parameters you see are pretty
common parameters and we found that the
the 55 degree
annealing step is actually
pretty important because the the lower
the temperature actually it improves
some of the separation of the signal
cloud of of reactions from the
background
and sometimes using a lower temperature
than that of the
recommendation for the tacman probes was
a good thing and we found that 55
degrees worked well for both of our
probes
so here's a close look at what the data
look like for individual samples
so
you can see for example for the n1 probe
that
that the the black square represents the
20 000 plus
reaction wells and each dot it
represents one reaction where there was
a pcr amplification
and we assume that each of those
reactions represents
one molecule of viru of viral rna from
the original sample so that's a pretty
powerful techn technique where you can
be counting individual rna molecules out
of your sample
and in the
the upper diagrams you can see the
poisson distribution represented so
the positive signal the positive
reaction
wells are indicated
above and then below the threshold you
see the large bulk
of the 20 000 wells
did not react and you see a similar
picture for the n2 probe
the
the hex 4 and then the ppmov is is the
control saying that yes we have
have
significant fecal wastewater content
here and you could tell that worked
because when students went away for
vacation students were actually
about two-thirds of the population so
the ppmov fecal probe went way way down
when the students were out of town
so here we see
a an overall picture of the results
from
[Music]
a couple of days that we looked at we
also compared
a
recent day's results in january january
12th with an with a frozen sample from
september
so if we look at the first at the left
half of the slide we see
for
for
january
we see the results of
the
threeplex probe and we can see that for
both
the
the hex and the fam okay the
the blue and the green you can see that
there is definite signal there so there
was quite a bit of
wastewater virus on those dates and that
was when students had just came back and
we had had a spike of cases shortly
thereafter
and so we can also see the control as
well now on the right hand side we see
the results of the omicron probe set
compared with
the older september date and
so
so the blue floor is the one that
detects the omicron specific probe and
you can see that
that on january 12 that probe shows
specific reactions where whereas the
control from the from the older virus
variant shows nothing
and
by contrast the frozen september sample
shows
positive results for the delta variant
and nothing for the omicron variant so
this shows that in fact we were very
precisely able to see
and there was another there was another
day also where it was mixed okay where
it looked like there was some delta left
and some omicron coming in so you really
can see
novel variants just by shifting your
probe
in terms of controls
there there we use two kinds of controls
one is the fecal control so that for
instance in in this well you can see a
little bit of
a couple of
special counts that shouldn't be there
so i did talk with the students
afterward about
making sure that the loading was good
and how to keep pipettes uncontaminated
um
the other kind of control is is your
waste water good so the the fact that
you we all we always found actually
increasing counts for the tenfold
dilution versus the five-fold dilution
means yes that's looking like real
wastewater because you're seeing the
result of
inhibitors as well
so we relied on
on internal self-control as well as the
the presence of the fecal control in the
threeplex probe
so for overall summary of what we would
have seen on that on on those days
so
we had essentially
four
replicas
technical replicas looking at
the n1 and n2 probe sets it was pretty
consistent that the n2 probe set showed
higher numbers and we generally use that
one for our community reporting you can
also see it was clear that that we were
seeing
omicron on the recent date and delta on
the older days
so
at this point i would say that
that we are continuing to use
the wastewater data that it continues to
be considered to be of use by the
community in fact
what we did is we we posted these data
on the
timeline graphs that you saw earlier and
uh people are saying well it's good to
have these data especially as the
community opens up and not everybody's
wearing a mask anymore and they don't
report all the cases community members
consider this really helpful to have and
have been able to understand
at the level that is presented we also
have an email list where we present
explanations of it
in addition
it's really important to know that this
is it's fairly straightforward and easy
to do this kind of monitoring i have two
undergrads who who conduct the analysis
and has also it's drawn interest in
further kinds of research
using this technology so what we're
doing now at kenyon is we're applying to
other questions
for example
drug resistance
and how do we deal with drug resistance
and the effectiveness
of
of antibiotics and multi-drug resistance
genes in fact
some reports are coming out showing that
actually
a lot a lot there will be a lot more
uh fatalities and morbidity due to
drug resistant bacteria in the next few
years than to something like covid this
is
really a pressing problem in fact it's
been amplified in the hospitals because
as more people go to the hospitals with
covid
then the the hospitals are are not
following up on drug resistance as well
as they should so we're looking at
research questions related to drug
resistant bacteria and a particular
question we're studying in our lab is
how do oral pharmaceuticals
and as well as phytochemicals in our
foods affect
the bacterial expression of drug
resistance genes
so when you ingest food you have all
kinds of phytochemicals including
organic acids and we have a hypothesis
that these organic acids affect
the
relative fitness of
the multi-drug resistance phenotypes in
bacteria and therefore can alter the gut
microbiome and make you more or less
drug resistant in your microbiome
so
we're interested in looking at
multi-drug efflux pumps which are driven
primarily by the proton potential and
the proton potential is affected by
organic acids that leak hydrogen ions
into the cell
so we're looking at
the specific question of how expression
of these drug pumps is affected
by
various compounds and so
this is an approach where we can use the
same
the same configured assay this four flex
acid using four different floors and
four different teclan probes
we can use
this to
simultaneously assay three different
multi-drug pump expressions as well as
the rpob control that's the rna
polymerase enzyme
expression as a control and so we're
just developing this application now but
we find that the data actually looked
very similar to the wastewater data
we designed specific
probes in this case we had techman
probes designed by a company that's
expert in that and
it
i must say that even on our first try we
got four tacman probes that work
well and they work actually following
the same assay configuration that was
used for the wastewater
samples
so we can use this as a to screen rna
preps from
bacteria cultured under
various conditions of ph and drug
exposure and then we can we can screen
many different conditions with this
four-plex assay and then identify the
most promising conditions for later
rna-seq follow-up
so we're finding the absolute q
and the four flex assays to be a really
exciting application in basic research
as well as for community wastewater
monitoring
thank you and i look forward to
to
questions in the question and answer
period
i would like to acknowledge all those
excuse me
so i would like to acknowledge all the
support that we've received from the
ohio coronavirus wastewater monitoring
network
we received a sub award from the ohio
water resources center and the ohio
department of health
and
the village of gambier was very
supportive and encouraging we also
received funds from kenyan college
office of the provost and i would
especially like to thank my students
bailey fitzgerald and lang lang yang lu
lu for their work in this wastewater
monitoring
thank you joan for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of our webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on that ask a question
box and click submit we will answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for
so joe we have some great questions
coming in i'm going to start with this
one
why did you select digital pcr as a
technology to quantify nucleic acids for
these applications
well digital pcr was recommended
by
some of the ohio state professors with
the
wastewater monitoring network
and
i had already previously done wastewater
monitoring by sending the samples out to
the lumen ultra company but
that that took a week's turnaround and
so i was impressed by the fact that this
technique the digital pcr
could count individual molecules of rna
and that it required a small number of
controls
and
so it looked like something that
would be easily doable something that
would be something that could be learned
to do easily and could give rapid
results
thank you our next question what were
the impacts
with the data collected for this study
on the community and
do you see this method being used in the
future as we hopefully transition into
an endemic phase of this pandemic
well the most important impact of the
data collection was
the confidence of the village community
and
the kenyan community of many kenyan
employees as well as students and the
village
saw this as
as
providing a picture of
the pandemic for them and gave them more
confidence in the overall kinds of data
that they were getting and it it helped
enforce the village mass mandate to say
well even if there isn't a case reported
today the wastewater shows there's still
virus present in the community things
like that
so in the future there's a lot of
interest in wastewater monitoring for a
whole range of viruses it can be used to
monitor influenza
viruses and
and enteric viruses noroviruses as well
so i think that in the future
that there will be a lot more of this
kind of technology
and joan what other environmental
testing applications do you see digital
pcr being useful for
so digital pcr is useful for all kinds
of environmental science for for
measuring small quantities of rna and
dna molecules
so
i think that it can also be used to
measure viruses in natural water bodies
we do
do
microbiome analysis of streams and pawns
for example
thank you
and what are the advantages of using
multiplex digital pcr over other methods
to measure gene expression
well the biggest advantage is that it
can be done rapidly
on
many samples and you get you get data
data back
soon and
it's it it has the the ability to
measure single molecules so the amounts
of rna that you use are tiny
we found that the amounts of rna that we
need for our for our bacterial preps for
example it might be
one thousandth of an rna prep is what
you need
for a run
and so the fact that you need such small
amounts of rna is really great for
research applications there are now rna
micro preps that have been devised
that
can
obtain
very small amounts of rna from a large
range of samples and you couldn't have
afforded to do this before so the fact
that you can get many different samples
from different conditions is really good
and
the fact that you can get this
information and then it also serves as a
cross-check for the rna-seq applications
because it's a different technique
that provides information in a different
way compared to the rna-seq
approach to gene expression
joan you've given us so much information
today we do have time for one final
question and we'd love to know what
additional information do you gain from
using this technology
so the main additional information
that we gain is that we can
we can
target specific
genes
in a system and ask questions about
those specific genes over a large number
of conditions say a range of
concentrations
of
an exposure pharmaceutical
so
it it's a technique that can enable us
to target specific genes and to detect
the smallest quantity of expression of
them
and of course you could also use the
technique to query dna
samples as well so that i have
colleagues that are doing
a mapping of dna
long
long distance mapping of dna in in
chromosomes and you can use the
technique for that as well
thank you joan now do you have any final
comments for our audience today
well i would just like to say that if if
you know any young people considering
colleges who want to do
science research that kenyan college is
a great place
to send them that they will get a real
science education and get
participation in state of the art
research and get to use great
instruments like the absolute cue in
their research
thank you again to our speaker joan
flandusky for her time today and for her
important research
we'd also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor thermo fisher for
underwriting today's educational webcast
now before we go i do want to thank our
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period they will be addressed by the
speaker via the contact information you
provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event thank you again for joining
us have a great day
you